[Musique]
elle s'appelle zinaida ndt au nova
corner bas et à 97 ans elle est devenue
du jour au lendemain une sensation sur
le web en russie décorez de ses
médailles la vétéran ancien canonnière
ne manque pas de récit pour alimenter
son nouveau site internet
les prix régionaux le train nous amener
à stalingrad les sergent-major nous ont
aussitôt appris à ramper sur le ventre
raconte denied à ce qu'en ville des
dizaines de vidéos quel public depuis
une semaine elle était d'un des tout
premiers régiments d'infanterie de
femmes formés par l'armée rouge à
stalingrad en 1942 et s'est rendu
jusqu'à berlin en 45 rejoindre les
alliés dont les britanniques ont mis ce
soit mais ensemble nous avons vaincu le
fascisme
aujourd'hui nous nous battons côte à
côte à nouveau contre virus dit zinaida
dans ce message particulièrement adressé
à celui qu'il a expiré en ces temps de
pandémie mondiale
car si lorsque la vue le capitaine tom
moore se donner des défis de longer à 99
ans cent fois par jour son petit jardin
de bedford chaillot royaux lui pour
amasser des fonds au sein de la co vide
qu'elle a décidé de se mobiliser l'oci
nous l'avons joint sur skype
un outil qu'elle apprivoise
tranquillement et déjà elle dit avoir
amassé plus de soixante mille dollars
avec l'aide de sa petite fille qui les
distribuera aux familles des docteurs
qui sont morts de la kfw 19 en russie ce
virus d'iter tout comme la guerre sans
pitié c'est ça qui est terrible
plus de 100 travailleurs de la santé
sont morts en russie depuis le mois de
mars dont au moins trois qui se serait
enlevé la vie
lui demande maligne comme tom en
angleterre je ne pouvais pas rester
indifférente au destin de notre peuple
car nous sommes et serons toujours des
combats ta fierté
zinaida devait d'ailleurs être pour la
première fois de sa vie une des invités
d'honneur du président poutine sur la
place rouge samedi pour le grand défilé
de la victoire mais ce n'est que partie
remise dit elle
au mois de septembre vous élaborez des
chaussures togo confinée à sa petite
datcha de saint pétersbourg elle se
consacre ainsi à sa nouvelle mission
raconter chaque jour ses périples de
guerre en échange de dons en argent et
entre du récit elle tricote débats
qu'elle a envoyé déjà hâte à mort pour
son centième anniversaire
75 ans après avoir mené la bataille de
sa vie zinaida sommes tous les vétérans
d'en faire autant et d'honorer à leur
tour sur qui mord aujourd'hui au combat
dans cette guerre absurde contre un
ennemi invisible si thammarat alter
escaut radio canada